after the big bang which is how far away
well we think actually we think that it
took place about 13.7 billion years ago
so we're looking actually at that at
that instant of creation of the of the
of the birth of the universe so to speak
I call it the embryonic universe and
we're kind of using using a very very
interesting technique to try to use to
measure the imprint of the actual birth
of the universe
I call it ultrasound taking an
ultrasound picture of the baby universe
so so with this you're you're a time
traveler you're looking back yeah we
look back telescopes are really time
machines when we look back in space we
see things back in time so I see you and
you too I see you at a time which is
later than I see say the distant horizon
which took longer time to get here so I
see that in a more early more primitive
state so we look in space we're actually
looking in time and we want to go to a
place and look at a place where there's
nothing that's going to get in our way
to interfere with that picture of the
early universe and the information comes
from all directions it's a background it
comes from all directions in space if it
comes from all directions why put
yourself in this frozen well the reason
is is actually what we're looking for is
actually a heat signature a heat relic
of the Big Bang so the Big Bang occurred
in the universe was incredibly hot and
dense all the energy in the universe was
combined to one place so imagine with
all that energy in one place was
extremely hot it cooled off over time
and now it's gotten to the point where
it's essentially a radio wave or what's
called a microwave so we study is called
the cosmic microwave background
radiation it means it comes in all
directions it comes in all directions
around us in space and it's in the
microwave region of electromagnetic
spectrum and so what that means is
actually if you have a microwave oven at
home as most people do a microwave oven
works by injecting electronic
electromagnetic energy into food but it
actually heats up the water inside of
food so water is very sensitive to
microwaves it absorbs microwaves and by
having a lot of water vapor in our path
it would absorb these very tenuous
microwaves which came from the Big Bang
so we need to go somewhere where it's
really dry and actually the South Pole
and the Antarctic
Continent is actually the coldest and
driest place on earth so it's as close
as you can be to being in space and at a
fraction of the cost so the main reason
is we get away from the water vapor by
going to such a dry place you've
probably noticed how dry it is and how
cold so you know you know wait I mean
this is this is like being on another
planet it is it is it really is giving
us an opportunity to observe as I said
it's its equivalent you know to some
extent to being at the best place on
earth to observe which is as close as we
can get to being in space as possible
and and it's about a percent of the cost
or so to build an experiment here at the
South Pole and we have all these
resources and even though it's difficult
as you know to get here it's still it's
still much cheaper and simpler than
getting into space to repair something
the other thing don't get too technical
but how how on earth can you see
billions of years into space using a
telescope with a sheet of metal well
it's basically it's a very simple
telescope it's it's a it's a refracting
telescope which means it uses a lens has
a lens that's about this big and the
light that comes from the early universe
as I said it's a background it comes in
all directions there are regions of the
sky where we want to prefer to look
because the sky has a mission that would
overwhelm our heat that we're trying to
look for just like the reason that you
wouldn't build an optical telescope in
the middle of a big city we're looking
for heat so we want to build it
somewhere where it's called so the light
is traveled all this way and the reason
that we as I said as we go the reason we
go here is to get away from water vapor
we don't want this photon that's been
traveling since the birth of the
universe itself to be absorbed than
anything so it's actually coming in all
directions and actually if you have an
old TV set at home the kind that's not a
digital TV set static on that TV set
actually a few percent of that static is
actually coming from the cosmos itself
so it's not it's not that the
electromagnetic energy that we're
looking for is so rare in the universe
is quite populous but it's it's very
tenuous and to look at them to look for
it to build this telescope we just need
to look in the region of the sky that's
that's clean that doesn't have something
in front of it called a foreground
something absorbing or emitting
microwaves which we tend to absorb it if
we do that we look back in space if you
look out in the night sky
you're seeing as far back in time as
this telescope is so that's the beauty
of this background it comes to us in all
directions so as long as they're not
something obscuring my view we can see
back to the beginning of time and
actually the human eye can do it and a
telescope you do it it just were not
sensitive to microwaves so if we were
sensitive our eyes worked in the
microwave we would see this amazing
beautiful color the color colorful blurs
and blobs in the sky about the size of a
full moon or so twice the size of the
full moon and that would cover the
entire sky with this beautiful pattern
our eyes don't work in the microwave but
if it did that's what it would look like
we would see it just the same way the
photons make it all this way and that's
the least we can do to make sure they
have a nice detection when they come to
earth and that they're gonna tell us
something very interesting about the
birth of the universe great great thank
you right here yes so one of the
benefits of being here is that it's
night six months of the year you'll
notice today the Sun will just move
around in a circle but it's slowly
spiraling down and when it gets below
the horizon it actually gets it gets
much colder so and it's much darker the
Sun is a very bright source of
microwaves as well so being here during
the winter when the Sun is down it's an
it's an incredibly pristine place for us
to observe right now the temperatures
have been negative 40 which is the same
Celsius or Fahrenheit and with the wind
chill it was close to negative 50
earlier today the cold net the the
coldness of the atmosphere keeps the
water vapor that that is so harmful to
us out of our way but that being said in
the summertime we don't get as much data
as we do in the wintertime because it's
minus 40 now your highness
when it's minus minus 100 exactly we pay
one guy to come here and we tell him as
a joke we tell him you only have to work
for one night and yet he can come out
and take pictures of the universe and
observe something that no human beings
maybe ever seen before in their lives
and that's yeah one that when the
temperature is called there the colder
the better for us we're looking for a
signature that's just a few degrees
above absolute zero so even even today
is considered a tropical day for for
what we're trying to measure minus 40
droppable weather exactly okay
thanks thank you great
so you want us to walk like around this
thing I Gracia here into the door and
okay tell me buddy well we're on it yeah
yeah so we're walking towards the
observatory's a ground screen it
protects us from seeing the surface of
the South Pole which is actually close
to 200 degrees above the temperature of
what we're looking for
so we're looking for this heat
temperature that's only a few degrees
above absolute zero the telescope shield
is in here the baffle it protects us
from wind and actually downstairs we can
work in our short sleeves and actually I
was one that it was basically the first
telescope that was designed to be to be
accessed and and outfitted and repaired
just with your short sleeves on nothing
is exposed the person that stays over
the winter the guy that we boondoggle
them to spending a year here he doesn't
ever have to come up here which is the
first telescope ever to do that at the
South Pole so that allows us to get a
lot more utility out of his labor he can
do it all in a comfortable warm
environment where we should head pretty
soon so we've got the the ground screen
that keeps out things we don't see the
the other telescopes there up here we
can't see the station it blocks out the
Sun when it gets low enough the moon
when it gets low enough and it's a
baffle that prevents it prevents snow
from getting into the telescope this
whole telescope can rotate and view 360
degrees around the sky and all the way
over and back so we can view the whole
hemisphere of the sky right great other
people that you know a photo credit down
there and then we can credit this
students and other investigators yeah
yeah yeah so email me when you get a
chance and we can go from here great
dollars probably that's a run-out cost
so they'll probably run out of between
20 and 30 satellites about a billion so
you're talking you know just a few
percent yeah this is really great that
you guys do it you know we do have the
best science in the world I mean no
doubt about it
and I think you know Americans should
should be you know they should be yeah
we do I mean it's it's the technical
aspects ok that would take you that's
beyond your capabilities just because
you know I spent my whole life my whole
career learning about no no the
technical stuff I'm not anything to try
to understand the technical stuff it'd
be like
it's the it's the scale it's the scale
the normal that's what's so appealing
about it you know you do the production
are you the producer okay cool and you
guys are all in San Francisco oh you are
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]